she was an active little girl who loved
swimming and dancing
but for the whole of ella kissy
deborah's short life she was surrounded
by
toxic air pollution living next to
london's busy south circular road
ella was regularly exposed to nitrogen
dioxide levels and particulate matter
in excess of eu and uk legal limits and
world health organization guidelines
she'd suffered seizures and been taken
to hospital nearly 30 times
in the three years before her death but
the original inquest
into her death did not include air
pollution as a factor
only after relentless campaigning by
ella's mother was this new coroner's
inquest
audit and the outcome is groundbreaking
this was about my daughter
getting air pollution on the death
certificate which we finally have
and we've got the justice for her which
is so
deserved but also it's about other
children still
as we walk around our city of high
levels of air pollution
the death of ella kissy deborah is not
just a personal tragedy for this family
it highlights a national and
international crisis
the uk has one of the highest asthma
death rates in europe
nearly 50 percent higher than the
european average
and researchers estimate that every year
four
million children around the world
develop asthma as a direct result
of breathing in traffic pollution in
britain
an estimated 1.1 million children have
asthma that's one in eleven including
adult asthma an average of three people
die of the condition
every day and it's a growing issue there
was a twenty percent increase in deaths
between twenty eleven and twenty fifteen
britain has repeatedly failed to meet
domestic and international legal limits
on nitrogen dioxide pollution
the mayor of london described ella's
inquest as a landmark moment
which should be a turning point he said
in public policy
what comes from this judgment must be
action
and it must be joined up government
action
to ensure that lives are saved
from that pollution there's a financial
incentive too
the uk national health service spends
around 1.3 billion dollars a year
on trying to treat asthma this inquest
confirmation of the need
not just to treat the symptoms of the
condition but to tackle the traffic
pollution which is one of its root
causes
paul brennan al jazeera southern
coroner's court